要把这个风险要讲明白，
因为真的有一天你的婆婆要承担赔偿责任的，
不还是你老公承担吗？
一个孩子死了多少钱赔多少钱，
你能赔得起吗？
出了事就是倾家荡产，
你赔不起。
我先介绍一下我的情况，
主要是婚姻方面的，
我和我先生25年5月份结婚，
在相处过程当中和他的家人有一定的矛盾吧，
他离我们的家600km，
我和我们的家也是40km，
相当于是我们两个都是异地，
只不过我更近一些，
他更远一些，
我平时就周末他上18休6，
他是一个单亲家庭，
父亲在他高中的时候因为医疗事故去世了，
有一个妹妹在读大四，
在家里面备考，
我周于上班的话，
周末在家回家基本上就是我和他妹妹相处的比较多，
那这个时候卫生呀，
做饭呀，
大部分事情就是我在做，
他回家之后这些事情都是他在做，
他妈妈因为家庭的原因嘛，
所以就在外面帮忙别人看小孩儿，
但偶尔会把小孩儿带回家，
就这一些系列的事情，
让我觉得我感觉心很累，
你的婆婆她是给别人当育儿嫂是吗？
对对对对对，
帮别人当育儿嫂，
有的时候不在雇主家里就直接把孩子带回家里了，
是吧？
对，
我觉得这个事还是有风险的，
因为你在别人家当育儿嫂，
你在别人家，
人家都装了监控，
孩子吃了什么用了什么啊，
都有记录，
你把孩子带到你自己家里去了的话，
万一孩子吃什么东西出现什么问题了。
哎，
很麻烦的，
对，
我跟我先生聊过这个事情，
我跟她不止一次沟通过，
我说做饭呀，
或者说卫生这个事儿可以双方互相做，
她说你直接跟我妹说，
家里住着你，
婆婆住着你，
小姑子还住着你和你老公还住着谁呀？
再没有了，
就我们4个人没有小孩儿，
对我没有小孩儿，
平时做菜吃饭是谁为主啊？
平时家里很少做饭，
周末我在家的话，
我偶尔会做，
我不想做的我就不做了，
他们妹妹偶尔会做那么一两天，
也是做早餐午餐，
大概我们就简单的煮点面条干嘛的，
也是我在做比较多。
为什么婆婆和小姑子在你没有生孩子的情况下要住在一起呢？
因为她是单亲家庭嘛，
可能在她爸爸去世的那一刻，
她就觉得她应该担负起当个男人的责任吧，
没有别的房子是不是？
对你对婆婆的不满意的点在于她把孩子带回来，
这个点你不满意是吗？
对，
是的，
因为我觉得家里面本身我对孩子也没说喜欢吧，
也没说排斥，
但是我不喜欢这个点，
而且那个孩子精力很旺盛，
晚上12点我都不睡觉，
吵得你没有办法睡。
那你对那个小姑子不满意的点是因为他不做家务，
不打扫卫生，
对以基本上就我自己在做，
那个房子是他的婚前财产，
你老公他挣钱怎么样，
挣钱多挣钱大概是我的一倍吧，
一个月大概1万左右，
你是5000左右，
是不是，
那你老公？
挣的钱了交给你吗？
对，
那钱交给你的话，
找钟点工打扫喽，
一小时三十，
四十，
两个小时就打扫完了喽，
对，
其实这个我也想过，
但主要的问题是因为我觉得很多时候我对他说，
我说家里的有一些问题，
因为我觉得我们三个女人都是因为他这个中介而就在一个屋檐下的，
我其实希望他能够理解我，
即便是语言或者说行为上的一些安慰我，
但是他在很多时候是对我，
让我感觉她让我自己直面的，
你去找他，
直接跟他说在你们当地租一套房子，
租个两居室要多少钱呀，
可能就是1000多吧，
也不是很贵，
那有没有一种可能，
小姑子和婆婆租个房子住呢？
我现在也就在考虑这个问题，
我现在主要是想问你一个问题，
我觉得这是一个别别扭的事情，
这是我的态度问题，
还是说我没事儿找事儿多的，
我觉得啊，
把雇主家的孩子带到家里面来带，
这件事情是有风险的，
你可能觉得不舒服，
但是你没有讲到风险的点，
对，
我没有抓到他们一个点，
你如果说是在雇主家里被装到监控，
吃的喝的用的都是家里的东西，
除了什么问题的话，
你们自己买的，
但你把孩子带到我这里家里来了，
万一吃了什么卡了，
吃了什么过敏了，
孩子生病了，
吃了什么，
有些风险真的很大。
跟你举一个例子啊，
你们听说过那个老年人的糖尿病的降糖药吗？
听说过吗？
那个降糖药小朋友只要吃一颗一颗。
就可以把这个小朋友给干那个什么，
所以这个事情你要跟他讲清楚啊，
跟你老公也要讲清楚，
到时候承担责任的话是挺大的这个责任的对，
因为我跟他这个沟通有问题，
他总让我直面跟他的家人沟通，
我觉得这个点可能需要她帮助，
但是她并没有直接帮助我，
让我觉得我觉得孤立无援的，
其实我觉得是这样的，
你要把这个风险要讲明白，
因为真的有一天你的婆婆要承担赔偿责任的，
不还是你老公承担吗？
你能赔得起吗？
出了事就是倾家荡产，
你赔不起。
最主要的问题就是我觉得我我在跟他的沟通上面也是有一些问题的，
我希望他能够帮助我的时候，
他并没有能够帮助到我，
你不要觉得他是在帮助你，
你要把这个损害要算到他头上去，
他不是在帮助你，
是他帮助他自己。
昨天跟他说了，
我说如果我们还继续这个样子的话，
那我们就分开吧，
他考虑了一段时间，
他同意了，
我现在自己又有一点点犹豫，
我是在想我是不是冲动了，
或者说我们之间是不是只有一个姐，
除了跟他家人相处之外，
我跟他是没有任何矛盾的，
只要他在家，
所有的家务，
所有的事情都是他来做，
他来承担，
人家都同意了，
表示人家也考虑过，
好，
我理解我，
我就是不死心吧，
我明白了，
好，
就这样啊，
拜拜。
一般情况下，
男的上来就同意，
表示他心里也有这个想法，
很多姐妹都说龙跟你说话太绝对了啊，
然后我也不排除有一些其他的可能性啊，
志气啊什么的可能性，
但是八九成吧。
你说分开他就同意的话，
表示他也心里那么想，
他之所以没有什么事都站在你面前去保护你的话，
他可能也想换人了，
他可能也想看你能忍到什么时候。
你知道我昨天听那个鲁豫老师的严重发誓，
其实我听到一个点，
我非常有共鸣，
那个点是什么呢？
就是鲁豫老师现在说话老喜欢说，
某种程度上其实就是被骂怕了，
被网络暴力怕了，
很多时候不敢表达自己的真实的意愿，
我现在也有这种感受，
有很多姐妹也觉得我说话太绝对了，
太极端了，
我以后我尽量委婉一点，
我也学鲁豫老师，
某种程度上人家已经想离了，
某种程度上人家已经人已够了，
某种程度上她已经考虑好了，
我以后我也学精了，
我也觉得鲁豫老师说话我留点余地，
我不说太绝对的话是不是啊，
就比如说我说爱是时常觉得亏欠，
博爱是时常觉得亏本，
我以后就说某种程度上记得点赞关注哦。